when it comes to the international
criminal court the philippine government
stand has always been consistent it says
it does not recognize icc's jurisdiction
over president rodrigo duterte and his
government after it has withdrawn as a
signatory of the rome statute in 2019
but the hague-based tribunal has
remained defiant and announced it will
open a full investigation into duterte's
so-called war on drugs which has killed
thousands of filipinos
the philippine government says at least
six thousand people have been killed in
police-led operations since 2016 but
rights groups believe that number could
go as high as thirty thousand
duterte's drug war is implemented across
the country many of the victims were
women and children and most of them come
from impoverished communities this is
why duterte's drug war has long been
seen as one against the poor
as long as uh
they give us at least a sliver of hope i
think it's not even just a sliver it's a
big window of opportunity as a chance
for the victims to have an alternative
if not parallel venue because their own
judicial system from their perspective
and perception have failed them
the investigation will also cover a
period when duterte was mayor of davao
city in the southern philippines where
prosecutors believe there has been a
similar repeated pattern of
extrajudicial killings
it's going to be a bloody fight
many believe duterte's rhetoric serves
as strong evidence their extrajudicial
killings in the philippines are
state-sponsored
even though it may take months or years
before witnesses are called to testify
or warrants may be issued families of
drug war victims already see this as a
moral victory and a step towards justice
they say president rodrigo duterte may
be popular domestically but he holds the
distinction of being the only filipino
leader to be tried and investigated in
the international criminal court for
crimes against humanity jamella
allendogen al jazeera manila